bon kazimi qu'est ce que c'est comment
s'est passée ta promenade en ville quasi
mort sabrina or au mal mal très mal fait
regarde j'avais fait une liste de plein
de choses que je voulais photographier
et puis je n'ai rien vu du tout quel
chercheur qui bien je voulais voir un
cochon des champs de blé des bars un
cochon des vaches
oui voyons casimir ce n'est pas dans les
villes qu'on peut voir des cochons des
vaches il vaut mieux aller à la campagne
pour cela tu crois d'investir
ça vous donne pas une idée de jeu vous
allez voir les enfants nés hors pair un
jeu d'accord je vais vous dire tantôt le
mobile est tantôt le mot campagne
et attention à chacun de ses mots vous
devrez me donner le dos rond d'un animal
lan objet ou une personne qu'on trouve
pas normalement la ville si j'ai dit le
mot ville et à la campagne
si j'ai dit le mot campagne tout le
monde a compris on fait un petit exemple
en france florent je te dis ville
qu'est-ce que dire du 10 maisons
ça peut aller à la ville et à la
campagne où les conjurés kazim il aussi
oui oui la quasi muet il à la barre
casimir
viens jouer avec nous casimir a bien
joué avec nous très utile oui du rien de
la ville d'acton appareil photo oui bon
on commence
michel ville saisie réponse et je te
dise il voiture tu réponds voiture nous
j'ai perdu non écouter jouer explique
alors il faut dire le contraire dire
quelque chose qu'on ne trouve pas la
ville si c'est la ville est pas la
campagne si c'est la campagne c'est la
dernière fois maintenant stéphane
derrière ville près vaches sophie ville
bien ça à gagner prévient florence à toi
campagne campagne campagne vile de cette
radio effectivement michel campagne
imad immeuble campagne encore j
usine ville cheval bien ouais euh
olivier ville va bien la campagne
voilà c'est les deux cd de la sophie
paris la ville campagne oui à la casse
non mais deux mois quand même le nom de
l'objet d'un animal ou d'un personnage
alors ville sophie un village c'est ça
florence ville que j'ai vraiment clara
très bien sophie lanthanides sopi
campagne à face à hull à la distraie
l'industrie comme casimir est très
facile comme jeu stéphane campagne
grâce à ces les deux insectes ou des
gamins casimir voilée que c'était facile
oui il s'est fatigué d'en face où ces
dons et son aura et nabil baha et bien
pourquoi c'est beau c'est mauvais c'est
mauvais bon allez on continue
lens entame un immeuble se fille
oui tu perds ta robe on interroge
plaisir alors casimir campagne pas tes
pattes et c'est pas bon ça un pâté un
pâté de maisons m'a pas fait de campagne